put a niche with the white pieces
against uh magnus so what should we ah
we don't have to speculate this is what
we can expect yeah he's uh opened with
his kingsport a lot lately doing some
chessable courses of course finish gary
on these types of openings so
no surprises yet these these guys have
faced each other countless times but
lately magnus has been getting the upper
hand against anish so anish i think his
strategy should be to attack magnus he
can't just make uh make the game too
quiet he has made some maybe unambitious
decisions against magnus in the past and
been punished for it so
whatever magnus chooses in the opening
i'm expecting giri to be a bit more
direct this time still waiting for
magnus to make his movement we do have
had to add scores between these two in
the meltwater champions chess store you
said it david they played each other
a bunch of times on the tour and magnus
he has won five games anish has only won
one game mine is obviously a big
favorite 22 drawers though
yeah it's uh it's a close one yeah 22
draws that's a lot of equal games there
but anish i think his score could be
better it's just at a critical moment
maybe giving magnus a bit too much
respect that's my only uh my small
criticism of vanish but of course with
the white pieces he's one of the best
prepared players out there
yeah and i remember from miami these two
played each other on day one in the fdx
crypto cup a month ago
and uh anish played a really good match
i remember but he did lose eventually
two games and lost the match yeah i mean
the kind of their games seem to follow
like a formula almost you know anish
will play a very sharp opening he puts
pressure on magnus and then you know
just when things get really critical the
tension gets a bit too much and it
fizzles out into a draw or there's a
perpetual or something like that
and
like as david referenced i do think the
school could have been more in anish's
favor if he just managed to sort out
those small moments in those very
complicated positions yeah
meanwhile what's up with magnus he
started started fast today normally it
takes him a bit of time to warm up into
these events but he started with a win
and a very nice win actually in game one
against eric icee okay he has arrived
and ready to play i mean he does turn up
he does turn up a bit late often and uh
um
i don't know if he's having internet
connections i thought the internet's
pretty good in norway
but he he often turns up late and i
always wonder why why oh they they've
actually reset the clock now should they
do that or should they punish him for
turning up late i'm kind of like
punish him for turning up late basically
um so i'm a bit surprised i said reset
the clock actually personally i agree
yeah
the game starts at a certain time so why
not start the clock very interesting
opening though at least i mean the park
and what we got on the board one of the
most aggressive
openings that black can can try to play
a little bit disappointed with anisha's
variation with white because he could
have gone for a much more aggressive
setup than what he's done here david
yeah i i agree don't say that simon
i've played this line with white myself
sorry
it's so ambitious but can i ask david
why so magnus with the black pieces
moving two pawns only one square when he
can move them two squares why what what
is the thought behind that maybe he's
forgotten how the pawns move kaia um i
guess the idea is black just wants to
stay nice and solid you want to let
white come to you and look at what
magnus has done he actually just brought
this knight out as soon as white stepped
forward he retreated it back to its
starting square so this is just
provocation he's asking white to come
too far forward and then he'll try and
counter attack do you know what david
this happened in our game as well you
know in all friday yeah i played a
slightly different set up but he played
the perk he put his knight there i
tacked it he went back
so it's yeah exactly the same thing he
literally goes to you as
a kind of sparring partner very worrying
the guinea pig there's someone to test
his ideas on i mean he likes this idea
quite a lot doesn't he because he often
says that white's uh a bit overextended
or he played at least a similar idea
against me yeah he has played this
before and or at least this idea in
olympiads even so very important games
and uh yeah as kai mentions it's
maybe not the most intuitive opening for
black losing a couple of moves and not
developing uh
kind of the most
to the most active squares but you are
very solid no weaknesses now white pawn
the deep one that's advanced very far
you can chip away at it you can try and
trade it off
and uh black's pieces they won't lack
for squares anytime soon so you're not
really suffering in terms of space
yeah it's uh it's interesting it's
definitely i think a tailored strategy
against certain opponents against you i
would never have done this simon because
you'd love to come forward anyway i
would never let you kind of come forward
free of charge giving you several moves
but maybe against a niche he's thinking
he doesn't really want to come at me so
i'm going to force him to
yeah and this is this is kind of key
already that you know if you're in a
niche's position
the reason he stumbled in the past
against magnus he hasn't been aggressive
enough you know he gets the point where
he gets a lovely position and then he
kind of he kind of eases off so he needs
to play super aggressive in this
position with a space advantage here you
know go for the king you know move them
you know just play natural attacking
moves there i think is the right way to
go about this yeah yeah meanwhile in
exchange of points yeah and uh the thing
is though in this type of position
natural attacking moves are not
necessarily kind of going gung-ho with
your pawns it's just really about you
know protecting your your some squares
for instance the g4 square push your
pawn forward connect the rooks take
control of that uh d-line
will we see uh anish do that magnus
meanwhile redevelops his knight this
knight's gone on a bit of a journey it
has already moved twice came back it
came uh
it went back to its starting square and
now it finally does sit on c6 and here
ivanka maybe talk us through so the rook
move you think is the most natural for
anish yeah but also potentially i i'm a
big fan of stopping off dark square
bishops i don't know why but i love
doing it it might not be necessarily
great here but sort of dark square
bishop put a rook in the center although
and then
yeah and then just
yeah exactly wait and see for something
to happen yeah the rooks will come
eventually you need to find a good space
for this bishop this bishop is often a
problem piece it's not 100 clear it's
best square the other pieces it's clear
where they want to be and uh yeah i like
this as well ivanka this is a very a
niche move i've seen him do this several
times against this modern kind of perk
setup in the opening just swap off
black's best defender black's
kind of nicest placed minor piece the
dark squad bishop and then
the game will continue i i don't think
it's
kind of the most
ambitious as you mentioned simon it's a
bit timid what white's been doing
i mean again it's just a niche maybe
against magnus showing too much respect
yeah i mean maybe swapping these bishops
all right i mean i would love to throw
the f-pawn forwards but it again
this is a very calm move right i mean
just it's not a bad move is it dave but
it's just like you know just i want to
see him really go at magnus you know you
can't he can still do that in this
position yeah
and uh one of the ideas you mentioned
there's simon for example if magnus
centralizes this rook just move this
knight out the way ideally you want to
use this square but you don't want to
trade pieces off
because black is slightly cramped but uh
if you could move this knight out the
way somehow
i didn't see a good square but at some
point start throwing this pawn forward
this is one idea uh maybe you can just
preface this by
bringing i'm sorry not the knight back
but the rook across first centralize
improve all your pieces
the problem is now you don't have the
opportunity to kind of force the
exchange of darts bishops if you try to
get rid of this defender at least now it
can retreat because there's now no rook
hit on the f8 square this is quite a
common pattern where white tries to
insist on an exchange black
says no
but uh yeah i don't like either simon
this kind of
slightly
kind of scary porn move
it's the type of move i would play to be
honest but i wouldn't be proud of myself
for playing it
it's just like against magnus you know
you've got this position and white is
slightly better in this type of
structure normally
black's very solid though and um just
historically you know when a niche has
gone for it against magnus and also
magnus doesn't really like to be
attacked i say the only weakness really
in magnus's game it's not really a
weakness because he's so good around but
the only thing you could say is that
when he gets attacked he sometimes you
know he doesn't like that situation so
it's just like you know you've got to
you've got to go for it here you can
still go for it um i still hope he does
you know combination of what ivanka
suggested getting rid of the bishops
maybe moving at night as you suggested
david and just
start flowing those pawns at the board
at the right moment just you know so
there's still time
and uh magnus has got to find some
counter play here as well i suppose
um or is he just going to sit here and
wait or
is the reason magnus is thinking for so
long now is it because he's tempted to
just completely blow open the center
push his pawn forward
if he can exchange everything off for
example if we see a mass trade here
capture a capture like he does play it
another capture we could see a situation
where
it's just completely symmetrical the
pawn structure
not much going on
just equality this would be a real
anti-climax but magnus he has initiated
this i guess with black as a success
you've equalized
solved all your opening problems but it
does maybe punish a niche for
we're going to see it aren't we just
everything getting hovered off
that's an evil laugh anchor i just
i just first
here it
comes the hoover's coming out
you know
the one game we picked for commentary
and they swapping them all off just what
we wanted
i don't know i was just chuckling away
to myself i don't know
sometimes i have these uh small moments
of madness yeah i mean i agree with you
the vacuum cleaners on the board
everything is going to get traded and
we're looking at in even stephen's
position
and whilst anisha is contemplating
on the future well
we have a tremendous surprise in store
for you all which we will show at the
end of this of the show and we are
asking for this to happen we need your
coolest chess pictures we need it
doesn't need to be chess selfies can be
whatever you find incredibly interesting
and uh they obviously knight takes porn
probably queen takes queen what do you
think
and
oh dear exciting stuff well we'll talk
about excitement i'm going to get
excited i'm going to uh
the pictures that you guys have sent to
us jessica says here's my chess selfie i
started to play chess seriously about a
year ago and just last week in my second
over-the-board tournament i took first
place in my section
that is incredible massive
congratulations jessica how cool that is
very cool i do like that picture and
meanwhile porn has stepped forward and
blocked the diagonal for the dark
squared bishop
and brian h live
says three world chess champions
signatures on one chessboard anand
karjakin and magnus carlsen that is the
best picture i have to say i have yet to
get a signature from one world champion
lelo in three very impressive brian and
i'm sorry was one of those plays a world
champion sorry not to nitpick or
anything yeah that's right actually
carry a kid no no no brian
harris certainly not a world champion no
he's a world champion loser
just uh just to say
i think he lost in the world
championship didn't he yeah
yeah 2016. yeah he came close though
yeah that was a great match
and in fact i i listened to a part of
the podcast where magnus carlson talks
about this match with lex friedman
and uh he
he said you know he was so angry with
himself you know he thought oh my god
i'm going to lose to someone who i know
is much weaker than me and that really
upset him
a very interesting podcast in fact yeah
well worth a listen
uh meanwhile this game
uh
i'm not sure it's well worth discussing
right now it's just completely level all
the nights have disappeared the queens
have disappeared
the structure is
completely symmetrical and uh i think
indeed it's very likely anisha's just
trying to work out he can swap
everything off here isn't he he's like
you know oh there goes another one well
done in these she's found a way to get
another pair of bishops off it's such a
promising position i mean magnus played
this great break in the center to get
equality and that move was the move
wasn't it that you pointed out david to
to and then maybe this is a fair as you
know fair way the game's going i was
going to say fair result
unless one side blunders of course it
should be a draw at this level even
evaluation bar agrees me for a change
that's that's quite remarkable right
valuation paul wants to get this one
done and over 0.00 that's as terrible as
you can get okay
okay
but okay say you had this position and
you're in a must-win situation
i don't think either player would have
played this opening or the last few
moves at least somehow other this is
what you've ended up with
go for it what would you do
resign mean
you just have to keep playing don't you
you have to keep playing you can't do
anything too ridiculous because if you
try doing something ridiculous well you
lose all your chances you've got to kind
of play play play play
and hope something happens but uh it
depends who you're playing as well if
you're playing magnus and
yeah i mean
you might as well resign i suppose um i
mean you can try to push your pawns to
create some chances uh something like
that on one side of the board
i mean
trying to make this position exciting is
really hard i mean you've got the open
file wow look at that white's
controlling the default amazing
what about another challenge just for
david now okay okay you need to break
the world record in longest oh
you just okay first you trade off all
the rooks
and then you just sit for 49 moves then
you push a pawn you sit for another 45
minutes you push another pawn don't
trade anything off don't break the pawn
structure just keep it symmetrical and
then eventually you'll get to move 270
the world uh one past the world record
car you were so close to getting the
world record one day one day and it'll
probably be against me don't do that
don't do that and
block it all up and then
i'll bore you to that side oh that would
be horrible i mean
how would you feel if like you're
defending this position for like 269
moves
especially if i was playing david
because i know he'd be enjoying it so
much
if i could just be like 8 o'clock in the
morning
even the arbiters are like
this
this is the basic actually so david if
you don't know had this game which was
like well i'll let you explain david
it's one of the longest games right but
the arbiters were doing this to you
right exactly i think it might be the
fourth or fifth longest game uh in
history and yeah the arbiters were just
looking at me shaking their head and one
of them was literally just putting his
arm on the back of my chair like
just kind of talking out loud and then
uh okay the game went on and on and on
it was eventually a draw and he said uh
you knew that was a draw right and i was
like
yeah but i was trying i was trying to
make some progress just enjoying the
game and he was like yeah but i had an
arbiter's party to go to
so
you ruined the party
and maybe their dinner as well
you never answered the question about
whether harry krishna
hates you now after after this or was he
in on it uh no i think we've bonded over
that we've got a shared experience eight
hours at the board
uh what what else can bring you closer
but you know what i mean like your
course grind like a grand master your
chess ball course which you've done with
uh with the world champion himself so
you can't get this on on chess ball if
you're at home you know great course by
two brilliant players um but it is a
strategy to win you know to actually
play equal positions like this you know
and just play until the death really to
kind of frustrate your opponent but just
try to get blood out the stone and it is
a very valid way to play chess why not
why can't you do that i mean people do
magnus does it so
it's a it's a strategy that if you like
doing it then obviously you're clearly
mental but you know some people do and
it does work right so you enjoy sitting
at the board and just kind of looking
for tiny little advantages and uh i mean
magnus himself when we were filming that
course together he was saying he he
finds the joy in that i mean this type
of position he doesn't look too excited
right now magnus but if he had this
position as black and was playing
someone 200 points lower 300 points
lower he would just be sitting there
thinking okay i'll push a ball in here
i'll just kind of create a tiny threat
later on and i'll just look to imbalance
it slightly and it's just kind of
you can play without any risk really and
i think that's the kind of beauty of the
course it's playing with minimal risk
and it's just finding
finding these kind of small nuggets
these kind of
small things to get excited about but
they do exist
i like that sentence
but uh yeah meanwhile anish thinking
yeah and uh talking about anish and
magnus obviously their opponents i do
have to ask you david do your opponents
ever get upset with you yeah
especially when it's just a draw
they look at you and they're like
right
has anyone said anything i mean once at
the english league the foreign i think
the game was 189 moves and my opponent
afterwards he was just looking i mean
even during the game he was just looking
at me like
and then i finished the game it was
actually for charlton our team at the
time and afterwards i came out and his
teammates were sitting in the bar
looking at me just because they missed
their dinner reservation because the
other thing is like at these team events
the whole team goes for like an indian
meal so they're always waiting for the
last person to finish we were probably
waiting for you dave because you were
definitely waiting for you to finish it
we could go and get our lovely indian
meal with our team and lots of nice wine
thank you for making us wait
i i had to try and win though we were
one point down in the match so i needed
to try everything and uh i actually got
opportunities there but yeah as magnus
said in that course in the intro uh he
was like he was joking i hope he's like
david beloved commentator but hated
chess player
hated opponent but it's a very valid way
to play and i've never seen anyone as
determined as you and i think that
determination chess is a mental sport uh
it's you've got to be in the right shape
of mind and just having that attitude
that you'll play every game to the death
you don't want to take draws will
immediately make you a stronger player i
mean no doubt about it you know if
you're like me you just want to resign
every position and what you're doing you
know become a commentator instead
so you know
criticize all those wolves
that sounds really bad
i can't play so i just criticize them
instead
yeah i mean this is you know the pawn
formation has changed it's exciting as
it's going to get
so oh david
0.1 yeah
you know this is something actually you
know look at black's pawn structure look
at anisha's face on the camera as well
aneesh
if magnus is looking at him maybe he'll
get a little bit of satisfaction joy
there but it's going back to 0.0
the computer
maybe we can jump in i mean we have to
just show
uh the tiny little bit of action that
has happened
so black did actually start pushing the
a pawn down the board this is one way
simon ivanka right to
just annoy your opponent slightly to
start pushing pawns on the side of the
board uh just gain a bit of space
and uh here there's a actual threat this
pawn is under fire white actually
captured this black pawn i was surprised
i thought anish would maybe just try to
be cynical and
i mean he already has traded off a bunch
of pieces he could have done the same
instead he captured this pawn
and now the small imbalance is that
these are isolated and
weak plaque is the better pawn structure
but white has maybe the better rooks and
there is a weakness to attack
it's hard to get excited even for me
it's hard to get excited here um you
could go after this black pawn okay he
doesn't do that now he tries
there is a trap where we have to
you know stay calm i mean if you're a
baby you might fall asleep
even then
you can grab a pawn it's for free yeah
what is it
and uh the trap is that after you grab
this pawn your rook is on a loose square
and loose pieces drop off so white's
bishop can jump out the way with a check
and uh this is also a discovered attack
once the bishop is captured the black
rook will fall
and it's just about okay here um you can
actually
create a fork so wait if we go back oh
sorry i just realized baby pounces yeah
if you take this pawn
we see a capture if i don't take with
the king if i take with the bishop then
rook takes rook i could
double attack your two rooks and uh
okay i'll win some material back it
still will be a draw but
at least you had some fun on the on the
way uh instead magnus doesn't uh worry
about this here the white rook would
move we'd see him oh he's gone hang on a
second
okay so he's gonna go for the same thing
so if we go back to the game position
now after rook takes pawn he's blundered
into this baby trap that we talked about
bishop takes born discovered attack
black's bishop recaptured and now the
double attack on the white rooks can't
believe he's blundered into another draw
yeah and this one is still likely to be
a draw
but it's changing maybe change it a
little bit isn't he and uh i kind of i
also think when i i don't know if anish
is playing for a draw so much but in
these kind of games i kind of like hope
the person who's playing so much the
draw gets punished
i finish right yeah i kind of think it's
also a natural way the game's gone
because magnus played this break
exchanges are very natural and i think
anish had to sort of back down from
trying to get the advantage
here it is a draw david and javanka but
it's uh you know which side would you
take your vancouver view i kind of like
the black side just because you know the
black rook can get behind the pawn
but uh maybe it's just going to fizzle
out in the into a draw because anisha's
played this part very accurately yeah if
we jump forward to the current position
uh black has temporarily sacrificed to
pawn but black will win this one and uh
yeah it's just a draw unfortunately uh
the rook is the wrong side for black
this rook is passive it's actually stuck
in front of its pawn it wants to be
behind the pawn supporting it propelling
it forward but
yeah i mean the black king now is cut
off the black king can never really help
the advance of its own pawn and we'll
just see a way for the players to repeat
nothing much to be done
it's going to be hard for white to
create a pass pawn it's going to be hard
for black
to push this one to the end the white
rook is perfectly placed
behind it so
i probably would choose black right now
but it's just a draw
it's just a draw and i think we'll see
that draw happen any moment actually
rook attacks the pawn the black king
will move another check and a repetition
over the next few turns
let's go back to the players it's uh
about to end
not the most exciting game
yeah and a decent result for both
players in the prelims but
our spectators
slightly disappointing yeah
39 moves uh still so much time on the
clock magnus carlson 14 minutes left on
the clock this game about to end in a
draw which means one point and 250
dollars for each player we're gonna jump
into another game when this one finishes
here in round two in the julie spirit
generation cup any second draw doesn't
it yeah no position repeats itself and a
draw yeah it is a jewel anish geary with
the white pieces uh two draws for him so
far today is a win and a draw for magnus